tiffany is with us in sacramento hi
tiffany how can we help
hi dave um i have a little complicated
issue here hopefully i can explain it
okay my husband had a job
change and real estate is different
in various parts of california and
we had to leave our home we're renting
it out we only owe
three and a half years on it now so we
because my
husband's job changed we left that house
but are renting it out
we owe three and a half years but where
we live now
real estate is super expensive
and so my husband wants to sell the
house
i have sent amount of value to the house
if we
if he lost his job we would go back to
that house
if something happened to him i would go
back to the house
so i feel like it's more advantage to
have a paid off house
and oh the only way we could buy a house
in the area that we live would have to
be a 30-year loan
so it makes me sad to think about
selling that house
and you know walking away with maybe two
hundred thousand dollars
and still having a 30-year loan am i
making sense at all
um well i mean i understand what you're
saying if that's what you mean
the uh where is the house
the house that we only owe three and a
half years on yes ma'am that's the only
one you've got right
yes it is in uh susanville california
you've probably never heard of that
no i haven't how far how far away from
you is it
four hours okay all right and you
left there because he took a job in
sacramento
yes do you feel like his job in
sacramento is going to end soon
no so how long do you think you'll be in
sacramento
um you know we have children that are
in college now or getting college age so
i really don't know i mean that's kind
of part of my reason too is like do i
really want to buy a house but then we
try and rent a house i mean are you i
mean are you going to be there two years
are you going to be there 20 years yeah
yeah yeah yeah two years 20 years
maybe not 20 years yeah how old are you
guys
i'm 46 my husband's 10 years older okay
all right so he's going to work 10 more
he's probably going to work 10 more
years anyway right
right yeah he suggested tennessee all of
us californians are moving to tennessee
now
okay so how would that take you back to
susanville
yeah right i'm not for moving to
tennessee i want to stay in california
oh okay
um
i don't think this is about the house
i think this is about you holding on to
susanville
right
why is the house sentimental
um
i don't know
it just is how long did you live there
right
um we were there about nine years was
that your first home
yes yes you know i brought my girls home
there
does it is it just because i hear like
security as well like if
something happens i kind of almost feel
like you're like you're grieving
the fact that you left there
yeah there's a lot of different greens
so
anyways yeah it's i just part of me
is yeah i'm attached to the house yeah
part of me
it makes me sad to think that i probably
wouldn't have a paid off house until i'm
close to 80. that great well i don't i
don't think that's true
what's your household income
um probably 180 190
okay so close to 200. yeah i mean i i
think you guys need to do some more
investigation of real estate in your
area
um i mean sacramento is a more expensive
market than susanville for sure
but it's not san diego and it's not it's
not san jose it's not silicon valley so
i i think making 200 000 a year with a
200 000 down payment you can do a 15
year
on something that you can find in the
area and get it paid off
and and have a game plan to have paid
for house i'm not signing you up for a
30-year mortgage
i agree with you on that but i think
you're overstating that
and adding some drama to this discussion
because your heart
is breaking about susanville somehow or
another
i don't know what it is i can't tell but
i mean you got
um you're not going back there
you know that logically but there's
something emotionally that says i can't
let go and i don't know what that is so
um you know i think that it's important
for you
and your husband and y'all's
relationship to work through that part
of it
and i think when you kind of come to the
conclusion that you're not going back
there you're going to sell it
yeah that's what it's what i would do i
wouldn't suggest you own a rental
property
four hours away that's paid for yeah um
i almost paid for um and so i'm going to
select a property with my 200 000
income in sacramento with a 200 000 down
payment
that's a 15 year fixed and i think you
can do all that so
um uh you know i agree with your
husband's conclusions
what i still can't find and
and i'm not i wouldn't come down on you
for this
but there's something going on with you
and this move
that emotionally that's causing you to
think to
to lean this direction and that's more
of a concern to me if
uh that for you guys going forward for
your relationship for your peace of mind
all that kind of stuff
then just whether or not you own a house
uh in susanville
yes i mean you can kind of feel it in
the air i really can
i i really can but i'm right there with
you dave
200 000 down payment home four hundred
four fifty max five three hundred
thousand dollars to pay off and then
hey uh uh and if something was to happen
and i hate to say this hopefully they
have proper term life insurance and they
take care of the house and she's
back to where she was you know she's
safe she's secure
yeah there's something about the past
that's
going on there i i yeah there's
something happening
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five thank you for joining us
america
so the thing to remember to
tiffany's credit and for it's a good
lesson from that call for all of us and
i i have to stop
and remember it uh not as often because
i've done this show for 30 years and it
keeps me remembering it but personal
finance
is personal yes and so
there are times with money
that it's okay to do something that's
illogical
or maybe not the perfect math thing
because it's what you were doing yeah
you know
it's like you wouldn't logically spend
what we spent on a diamond for an
engagement ring or a wedding ring
right it's not logical it doesn't it
doesn't match the numbers
it's not a return on investment in terms
of mathematics
it's a personal thing it's a gift to
your betrothed
and so it's okay for it to be personal
it's okay to have feelings
about all this in other words